bien pues vamos al problema número 6 que
está en la página
670 y dice problema número 6 si el
promedio de 6 y 6 y 12 y 16 y x esto es
igual a x el promedio es x este ejemplo
en el equipo el promedio de estos es x
entonces lo que me preguntan es cuánto
vale x ok pues esencialmente cuando nos
tomamos el promedio tenemos que sumar
estos datos es decir 66 + 12
16 más x y dividirlo entre la cantidad
de datos que tengo que son 1 2 3 4 5 y
dividirlo entre 5 pero yo sé que este
promedio es igual a x por lo tanto de
una vez déjame hacerlo igual x igual a x
ok y ahora qué pasa si yo sumo esta
cantidad de arriba me queda 6 6 12 12 12
es 24
16 es 40 40 más x entre 5 esto es igual
a 5x y si ahora multiplicó por 5 de
ambos lados de esta igualdad
qué 40 más x es igualar
a
525 no esperes ver aquí hay algo mal
este 5 no debe de estar esto tiene que
ser igual a equis perdón y ahora si se
multiplicó por 5 de ambos lados de esta
igualdad y lo hacemos con mucho cuidado
sin que el cerebro esté funcionando mal
me va a quedar igual a 5x ok perfecto y
si ahora restó x damos lados de esta
igualdad voy a obtener que 40 es igual a
4x o dicho de otra manera x va a ser
igual a 10 x va a ser igual a 10 porque
yo he dividido ambos lados de esta
igualdad entre cuatro y hasta x igualdad
10 es el insisto de y es la respuesta de
este problema si yo sumo estos datos y
los divido entre 5 con x igual a 10
obtengo que el promedio es 10 así que
bueno vayamos al siguiente problema
problema número 7 y tiene un triángulo
muy parecido a éste así que problema
número 7
perfecto déjame poner esto para acá y
vamos a ser el triángulo tengo un
triángulo muy parecido a éste después
tengo algo así algo más o menos por aquí
y después tengo algo como por acá ok y
por cierto tengo una altura tengo una
altura muy parecida a ésta esta es una
altura y si es una altura entonces estoy
diciendo que este ángulo vale 90 grados
más de 90 grados y qué datos me dan
bueno pues me dicen que este ángulo se
llama z este de aquí se llama z este de
aquí se llama james y este es dos veces
y es 2 james y me dicen que este ángulo
vale 40 grados y lo que me preguntan es
cuánto vale z así que hay que cazar a z
en estos ángulos y creo que no es tan
difícil fíjate bien si yo tengo aquí 90
y 40 entonces yo sé que la suma de estos
ángulos de este triángulo que tengo aquí
me deben de dar 180 es decir que 40
grados este de aquí más este de acá
90 grados más estar acá esto más 2 james
tiene que ser igual a 180 grados o dicho
de otra manera 130 grados más 2 james
esto tiene que ser igual a 180 grados y
si ahora restó 130 de ambos lados de
esta igualdad obtengo que 2 james es
igual a 50 grados o de otra manera james
es igual a 25 grados ya está ya tengo el
valor de james y para qué me sirve
porque entonces yo sé que james aquí
vale 25 grados este vale 25 grados éste
equivale 50 grados y ahora sí puedo
obtener el valor de z porque si este es
un ángulo recto
entonces éste también tendría que ser un
ángulo recto y si ahora me fijo en ese
triángulo que tengo aquí entonces yo
puedo decir que zeta ceta más
+ 90 grados como están adentro de un
triángulo tienen que sumar 180 grados
180 grados o dicho de otra manera z
tiene que ser igual a 90 grados
si yo restó 90 de ambos lados de esta
igualdad pero ya que lleva la 25
entonces z más 25 grados esto es igual a
90 grados a 90 grados está utilizando
que vale 25 lo estoy insertando justo
aquí y después
si yo paso este 25 del otro lado me va a
quedar que z es igual a 90 menos 25 en
lo cuales 65 z vale 65 grados que es
justo lo que me preguntaban y por cierto
es el inciso c ya está problema número 7
vamos al problema número 8 creo que no
estaba bastante fáciles así que vamos a
ver qué me dice el problema número 8 un
programa de computadora de manera
aleatoria selecciona un número entero
positivo de 2 dígitos
ok vamos a seleccionar un número entero
y además positivo de dos dígitos si el
número seleccionado es impar el doble de
centre o se imprime en la pantalla ok si
es impar impar y por cierto estamos en
el problema número 8 si es impar
entonces en la pantalla se imprime dos
veces es el número supongamos que ese
número se llama n entonces si n
si n es impar entonces en la pantalla va
a aparecer dos veces en el doble de ese
número ok ahora me dice si n
en
espa
entonces se imprime en la pantalla es el
número tal cual se imprime ese mismo
número por lo tanto si en spas se
imprime simple y sencillamente en ok
cómo están si el entero que se muestra
en la pantalla es 26 es decir me están
dando el dato de que en la pantalla
yo veo solamente el 26 y lo que me
preguntan cuál de los siguientes podría
ser uno de los enteros seleccionados ok
no está tan difícil tampoco fíjate bien
si en es impar entonces tendría que
obtener 2n y 100 es par obtendría en él
pero yo solamente veo el 26 entonces de
una manera sencilla podemos concluir que
si en españa si en espa
entonces en entender que ser 26 en es
igual a 26 porque n s de un número
positivo de dos dígitos entero y además
como es par se pone en la pantalla tal
cual el mismo por lo tanto llegamos a
este 26 ok ahora habrá forma de que en
el fuera impar bueno pues vamos a ver si
n es impar impar
entonces me estarían diciendo que es la
pantalla y yo obtengo dos veces cn dos
veces n y me están diciendo que estos 26
dicho de otra manera si n fue el impar
en este caso en el día 26 entre 2 lo
cual es 13 y 13 es un número de dos
dígitos positivo entero y además es
impar por lo tanto también podría ser es
decir que este problema tiene dos
soluciones o que en ese a 26 y entonces
se imprimen 26 o que n sea 13 y entonces
es un número impar y en la pantalla se
imprime dos veces 13 que es 26 ok y por
cierto la respuesta aquí es
2 1 y 2 y esto me da de solución el
inciso c ya está tengo aquí el problema
número 8 y vamos a hacer el problema
número 9 déjame borrar la pantalla y
vamos a hacer aquí el problema número 9
y por cierto en las opciones que tenía
en el problema pasado estaba
5252 es el doble de 26 y lo que buscaban
era que nos confundiremos y pusiéramos
una respuesta incorrecta pero bueno ya
eso es pasado y ahora el presente dice
problema número 9 cuántos segundos hay
en n minutos y ese segundos es decir
tengo m minutos m minutos minutos y
tengo s segundos segundos y esta
cantidad de aquí la tengo que expresar
en segundos cuántos segundos hay
en minutos y en s segundos ok bueno pues
los segundos ya están en segundos por lo
tanto esta parte al final tengo que
sumarle ese ahora fijémonos en m minutos
m minutos cuántos segundos tiene un
minuto a ver si yo tengo un minuto un
minuto esto es lo mismo que 60 segundos
esto lo sabemos muy bien si tengo dos
minutos dos minutos bueno pues esto es
lo mismo que 60 por 2 60 por 2 segundos
es decir 120 segundos si yo tuviera tres
minutos tres minutos pues bueno esto es
lo mismo que 60 por 360 por tres
segundos es decir 60 más 60 más 60 lo
cual me daría 180 si yo tuviera por
ejemplo a 100 minutos 100 minutos
entonces pues para saber cuántos
segundos tengo yo multiplicaría sesenta
por cien porque es de cada uno de estos
minutos yo tengo 60 segundos y son 100
minutos entonces tendría 60 por 100
segundos
es decir 6.000 segundos y si yo tuviera
por ejemplo en minutos n minutos
bueno pues siguiendo esta misma lógica
tendría yo tendría 60 por n segundos
segundos ok y esto ya está apareciendo
sé mucho esto de acá arriba n minutos el
60 por ende segundos m minutos en
minutos minutos pues voy a utilizando la
misma lógica de aquí esto sería lo mismo
que 60 por m segundos ok es decir que
esto de aquí no puedo expresar como
60 por m segundos 60 ponemos segundos y
aquí ese segundos pues lo voy a dejar
como ese segundos por lo tanto si yo lo
que quiero saber es la cantidad de
segundos que tienen estos dos de aquí
pues habrá que sumar los 60 m más s
segundos 60 m
+ s todo esto son segundos segundos es
decir que mi respuesta de este problema
es tener 60 m
+ s segundos 60 m más s segundos
segundos son los segundos que hay en m
minutos y en s segundos y es mi inciso y
ya está
así que hemos acabado este vídeo y nos
vemos en el siguiente